alors bonjour, nous sommes ici de
reporters sans frontières pour remettre
cette pétition
euh appelant les autorités britanniques à ne pas
extrader l'éditeur de wikileaks julian
assange vers les états-unis
nous avons plus de 80 000 signatures à ce
jour et la pétition reste ouverte comme
tant que la procédure au Royaume-Uni se
poursuit,
nous n'avons pas été en mesure de remettre notre
pétition en personne au numéro 10 parce que le
numéro 10 a donné des instructions euh à
la police qu'ils ne
recevront aucune pétition en raison de la gestion d'
un personnel réduit
à la lumière de  mais notre point est qu'il
s'agit d'une démocratie, le Royaume
-Uni est fondé sur des principes démocratiques,
y compris le droit du public de pétitionner
notre gouvernement euh, nous sommes donc très
déçus de ne pas avoir pu
remettre cela, mais nous le mettrons dans le
post
parce que le premier ministre ne peut ignorer
cet appel de plus de 80
000 personnes à ne pas extrader julian
assange vers les états-unis